chat she got it
we are live
amazing good afternoon everybody hope
everybody's well I'm looking at the chat
I'm looking at May and Ben from be
friends but first I want to interact
with the people on the chat and here we
go Eve Z great to see you Jessica V uh
thank you for being here
Arana uh my comments are not streaming
you're probably getting too many TV
scales there we go Sasha Marie great to
see you that's what platforms are we on
right now
Facebook LinkedIn YouTube and Twitter
love it and what about Instagram nope
no
cool I'll do something with that I know
what to do
what's that Instagram nope
no no worries I will do something with
that Ben may please say hello real quick
Hello friends this is May director of
community strategy here I'll be friends
hi this is Ben head of merchandising and
collaborations for egrets
so Ben let's start with you real quick
actually uh just to go into a team what
I plan on doing everybody uh who's on is
we are going to actually I'm going to go
on Instagram real quick Ben why don't
you talk a little bit about your fashion
background for one second because I just
want to get everybody on Instagram noted
on this
sure yeah
um I worked with Gary for five years now
but I've worked in the apparel industry
for 15 years everything from the
marketing and brand strategy side to
licensing to production and design and
like I said I came over and started
working with Gary about five years ago
but in the last year uh when the friends
really got popping him and Andy asked me
to come over and oversee all of the all
of the apparel
well everybody who's watching right now
and joining first I'm going on Instagram
right now to tell everybody that we're
live
um
couple things one the new winter
collection of V friends swag has
launched May is uh modeling May is
modeling the patient Panda hoodie uh I
just posted on Instagram uh a post about
it my the uh oh very nice Bank uh Dustin
if you could put up the URL to the shop
uh I plan on giving away a couple of
pieces uh during this session on Twitter
so if you have a Twitter account
everybody on Instagram I'm live on
uh YouTube right now LinkedIn Facebook
and YouTube so please go check it out uh
well what's good I'm gonna sign off but
I wanted you all to know we're live
right now on those platforms and so we
just dropped the new collection of uh V
friends and um I'm uh I'm excited about
it so I'm signing off but I just want to
come in here and say what's good what's
good please come and check us live we're
now live on Twitter right
um Dustin yeah we are oh we are sorry
and Twitter everyone and I'm gonna give
away a few pieces on Twitter also check
my latest Instagram post and the URL to
the shop is in the bio I'll see you on
YouTube or Twitter somewhere see you
later all right off Instagram now back
to everybody here I want to look at the
comments Crystal f with the fire Jessica
V likes it Jeff p on LinkedIn
um I want to talk about the attributes
Ben when we do launches we do the
Evergreen stuff yes and then we and then
we focus on certain characters May is
rocking the patient Panda but what I'm
really focusing on is the traits right
so that's the Evergreen stuff and then
I'm really what I want to talk about
here and Dustin are we able to get one
or two people to ask a question about
patience or selflessness can you make
that work
I could
uh highlight their comment but getting
them onto the stream will be a little
okay we'll highlight the comment I like
that so Ben which which traits did we
decide to focus on yes
patient
um selfless competitive
grateful and authentic we're the we're
the five and of course we're always like
looking to pick five different
characters five different designs every
season
so
patience
which I talk a lot about competitiveness
which I'm starting to talk a lot about
selflessness which I touch on but might
be a good thing for a lot of people here
uh to think about what are the other two
my friend I apologize
authentic and um the Anaconda
authenticity
right so gratitude yeah the Grateful one
The Grateful gar is the hoodie I've been
rocking for a little while so everybody
those are the uh the
um the traits we focused on you're
seeing two of them here visually
um I think we have a lot of other people
rocking uh some of them as well right
yeah for sure NG on the on the patient
Panda
um that is your actual handwriting like
that's your hand style from when you
first no you made me do it I know
exactly
um so we get because you talk about
patients so much we definitely wanted to
ensure that it definitely had a very
very real tie to you
and then Richie hustle's Big Love to You
on YouTube TJ Anderson great to see you
there's the selfless yeah
as you know I've been traveling the last
two days been fairly Off the Grid I
noticed this morning for a quick second
as I was driving to the LA office that
those without the hoodies it says tea
on the webs on shop.b friends.com is
that right like like to me that makes me
think t-shirt but is that the official
terminology
yeah there's a there's a long sleeve
t-shirt like and then an actual short
sleeve t-shirt
yeah like this I saw this
right like the selfless right t-shirt
okay it's lighter it's not like uh it's
not like this tea or a whack thing that
I'm wearing it's not like a um
material it's t-shirt material just a
long sleeve yeah
a really special one because it came
right from how you always talk about
selflessness about being like focusing
on yourself first and then when you're
in a good place that allows you to be
self selfless right sorry I'm trying to
make sure you can see it
but like
right if you focus on yourself first and
then and then you're able to focus on
others afterwards
if you if you don't demonize being
selfish
and you realize that you have to be
happy and in a good place like the only
reason I'm able to be selfless is I'm
good most of the people that I interact
with which you know are friends and
family that I know deepest the ones that
are incapable of generosity emotionally
are the ones who aren't good and so for
me there was something along the way
that made it obvious to me I'm like oh
I've got to be good before I can help
anyone
and like so much of what I see
manifesting in the world is someone not
being in a good spot and then thus
lashing out
and so yeah I'm very I'm very passionate
about being selfless however
selfish sounds like a really bad thing
in our world but I actually think it we
need to and there's listen I view it as
more of you know I use it as slang it's
really being content and at peace
but yeah I'm very into this selfless
sloth like you know like I just think um
I just I really like that combo and I'm
really happy about it
I feel like a lot of people in the Be
Friends Community are super selfless
like we see a lot of people giving a lot
to the community members and making a
lot of friends but really like when it
comes down to it you really have to take
care of yourself first so I feel like
the little blurriness that shows here is
like super on board
yeah it's much more clear on the website
than it's here but I see it like it's
really rad
um okay what else do we have I want to
show people more stuff and then I really
want to ask questions by the way for
Dustin who's on here right now please in
the comments Crystal Groves good to see
you Joanne m Jermaine J if you have any
questions
please put hashtag question first like
if Adam Maguire right now on Adam M or
Brian Reed if you have a question of any
kind put hashtag question and then ask
your question my preference is that
they'd be around some of the themes
we're talking about here uh and then
we're gonna do a Twitter thing at the
end where I'm gonna give away some of
the stuff what we're talking about here
if you're just joining us is the new
winter collection of be friends swag has
hit the market it is available at
shop.mefriends.com Ben May what do you
got to show us next well before we go
there I saw Kelly had a comment and she
said how does it fit I'm 5'4 and I'm
wearing media right now it's very cozy
feels really good on the body
um I like it a lot Ben this was
something I saw in the chat yeah they
said if the hoodie is hard like
cardboard I'm going to come to your
office Gary and return it to your
personal plan and said me too
um you know I yelled at Ben and said the
last set was 2 too you know rough on me
I like softy soft can you explain to
people from a technical standpoint of
them common English
for the people that bought the last set
what the softness factor is compared to
the last one yeah and you're right you
definitely heard I heard you loud and
clear in the community loud and clear
and if you look at the actual not to get
too much into the details but if you
look at the makeup of the material the
first launch was 100 cotton and a really
heavyweight sort of
um rough cotton like it was and then
these now are 80 cotton 20 polyester so
it's a bit of a lighter feel and also
the poly action gives it like the softer
touch that you're looking for so um it
we did hear you all loud and clear and
you should notice a significant
difference where
Adam rips what are your thoughts without
being a don't be [ __ ] here like do
you like hard because you're cool like
then and you're all [ __ ] you're a
hype beast and you like that or are you
a little bit more soft and not cool like
me and you like that you're a
competitive clown hoodie here is soft
and cozy and you're good yeah I I like
the style
um a lot softer feels like you can like
go to sleep in it more than the last one
and uh I want to describe myself as a as
a soft one but I enjoy I enjoy the
quality a lot of work is a lot more
coffee well you're soft like if I
punched you in the stomach you did it at
the Jets game and I took it pretty well
that's true and I actually actually to
give you a ton of compliments I love the
way you play basketball and so I would
actually argue you're right you're not
soft and I find you very competitive and
so when I saw you just roll up modeling
clearly for the first time in your life
uh I'm excited to see that you're the
competitive clown this is my first time
I wish I would be proud to be debuting
and uh the competitive clown turns are
found upside down like that
um then talk to me about the sizing I
saw a lot of people talking about that a
lot of people are going to go right now
and uh and yeah you know here's a
question about do we carry Biggins and
to all sizes talk a little bit about
that but then also I've been Rocking The
Grateful gar
yeah back to like literally I've worn
The Grateful gar sample
more than I bought the last collection
combined because it is soft but you got
me a medium and the sleeves do go kind
of the cool stuff ah there it is why
don't we allow her to say hello to the V
Friends Community good hi guys how are
you I'm Nia Spencer I do cultural
engagement management
for me like I don't know if you rock
this size like do you find this goes a
little large because for me the medium
hoodie it goes a little like I actually
I'm gonna buy a small Bend because I
want to see how it fits on me is this
rocking a little bit like talk to us
about it yeah it's a it's a little
oversized like that's the the look and
feel however the first drop right in
September was like a little more boxy
this and you'll see it you get like
there's still a bit of a drop shoulder
like it's not technically a drop
shoulder but it is a little like
oversized fit but it's coming a little
bit in terms of the the width and like
come a little longer so there's a little
more length and everything and a little
less width so it isn't like a by the way
in the comments I'm reading right now
like you and Nia like you guys are cool
like people want the oversized no but
honestly let's call it what it is yes
you are and so like people do want the
oversize I just don't 100 and and G it's
not like we lost the oversight it is
still oversized but every draw we're
gonna get somebody like me who's
normally meeting him and it went to here
like I might win with a small right
you'll be fine small will be fitted
right so if it's like
yeah you should buy your true to size if
you wanted a little oversized if you
want fitted you could size down for sure
so we have double XL I saw some people
asking we're up to double XL right yes
and small this is small by like let's
talk normal English because some people
want it
yep sorry did you ask something G
I ask small how should they consider it
and then RJ's got a question that I'll
that I don't know if you can see but uh
Dustin will give it to you like I I
would say everything is a little baggier
like a little more oversized than true
to size so if you if you know PA
Explorer says these prices are absurd
honestly in the Discord so I want to
address that from your perspective you
know I give you a lot of creative
freedom yes you know you're playing a
little bit more to that hypebeast crowd
that super premium fashion set
when you see the comments on Twitter or
in the Discord these prices are absurd
you know do you feel like you know I
mentioned to everybody I was going to
talk to you on Friday Saturday or Sunday
or Monday yes you think you need
something more in the 40s kind of like
that champion kind of like that style
like like explain to people why
something like this could be a hundo for
a hoodie like that like what are what
are you trying to accomplish or what do
you know about the fashion industry that
might make someone better I would I
would say two things you like
like obviously everything has a price
and a better quality gets the more the
price goes up right
um we're also at a spot where we're not
making tens of thousands of their
redesign right they're special pieces
um that affects the price right but
overall I would say we're not taking
blank hoodies existing t-shirts and just
printing graphics on them these are our
own fabric it's our own construction our
own fit we're like trying to get the
exact feel that you all want there's
heavy like high high detail clean
embroideries on these pieces we don't
even call these pieces as you know we
don't even call it merch right like
these are like apparel pieces that
aren't made to be disposable this is in
fast fashion like you always talk about
patience in the long game and everything
we're making pieces that have to match
your lifestyle these things need to last
in the long term so it's a quality play
right these are high quality pieces that
we're all developing from scratch like I
said our own colors our own fabric that
plays into the cost
um again like people that know the
apparel industry there's like all types
of inexpensive blanks like Guild and
blanks are called or whatever all style
blanks we're not doing any of that right
these are all our own thumb scratch
pieces and the price matches the quality
I would actually say this
like I said I worked in apparel for 15
years if I was at a different company
and we were making apparel at this
quality level and paying the prices that
we're paying to make these pieces the
end price of the customer the retail
price would be way higher and I don't
even talk about that you're saying the
price should be lower and keeping it
lower for the community because you want
it more accessible I gotta just give you
your flowers on that no no but I to your
point like I think for you know like the
buying power of something like you know
an Essentials is going to allow them to
have margin that's greater than ours
even at a higher price point I
understand but I just want to make sure
people can hear you know NG also too
like everyone sees what's going on in
the world prices of fabric shipping dies
and to the point of the people saying
this is expensive there's a recession
yes but the supply chain and the cost of
goods are through the roof and that's
why anybody watching right now the last
thing on [ __ ] Earth that I'm
interested in is anybody
purchasing one of these if this
stretches them do not do that all right
let's go let's talk about gratitude how
do the two yes sir I'm gonna ask how the
two of you that both of you Nia so be
ready think about gratitude but go ahead
finish your final thought just the last
thing on it is like also in the
strawberry you gave 555 of these teas
away like that also like plays into like
the value of what people are purchasing
and the last thing I say I encourage
anybody by the way that's that's gone
for anybody who's watching when we
promoted this earlier this morning the
first 555 orders got that t-shirt
defense wearing for free we've eclipsed
that so I just want to make sure
um that nobody acts on that keep going
brother and just pricing was I encourage
anyone like you don't have to take my
word for like look at the market go to
the Supreme Sereno Palace kith like look
at what hoodies that are this quality
and have this much thought and
consideration put into them like are
going from the market with you can't
find an embroidered hoodie like this
quality on any of those right go to Kit
Supreme go to work and those are like
and the reason those things are more
expensive is they are so cool that
people buy them to flex I you know our
brand is not there yet but on the flip
side to me what I'm excited about is
rocking something that says grateful or
selfless is like the thing that really
is exciting to me you know what I mean
you know those those brands have earned
that so that that I just wanted to
answer that question that's popped up a
little bit let's move on to the essence
of what's going on here a couple things
one
talk to me about grateful when you when
you two hear that ladies first what do
you think about yeah go ahead
um appreciation of like being thankful
for all the things in your life and like
the great parts of your life so I
thought this was like are you are you
are you able to do that Nia like is or
are you like 99 of the 8 billion people
on Earth that you you're more capable of
seeing what's not going as well as you
want versus breaking things down to
Simplicity and being like I'm grateful
for what like on some real [ __ ]
um like to be honest of course like as
soon as something happens I'm definitely
thinking in a negative sense and then
once I start to think it out I start to
become grateful and think about like at
least I have this instead of thinking
about what you don't know if I start to
think about what I do
you know I get it
um so what about for you Ben
just that like when we were designing
this and said Gary we're thinking you
talk about like people ask you how do
you have this energy all the time right
and how where does all your energy come
from and you always talk about gratitude
and gratitude for the health of the
people in your life and your
relationship and time with the the
important people in your life right and
we actually built this out where the
flower that's on it like that's going
through the grateful that I'm kind of I
forget the name of is a flower that you
often give to people to symbolize
gratitude for them so like all there's
all these sort of like meetings that
we're like extracting from the things
that you've talked about over the years
and like building them into the product
and so I got to figure out I can't
remember what the name of the flowers
but this is a flower that you give to
loved ones or people that you have uh
gratitude for because you always talk so
much about your energy coming from being
so grateful for the people in your life
that's how this this graphic came to be
and I know you know that just
I love that thank you Neil let's let's
do we have any other pieces to show
let's go back to competitive real quick
yeah I just wanna I wanna know to rips
and to you what competitive means to you
guys
he's coming quickly
um it's funny I just
um for me it's constantly like the idea
of just like trying to get better
um often like looking at like what I'm
doing and what I'm working on and just
like the typical sort of like
competition with yourself knowing what
you want to achieve and what you want to
accomplish and focusing on those things
if you're competitive when you're
younger you don't have you're not as
sensitive or as uh vulnerable when
you're older so I like your sayings of
no way to place trophies kids learn when
they're young to lose
um and it also kind of instills more
ambition and motivation in people
growing up so I was always pretty
competitive
um I think that it's funny that the
cloud is competitive because people
don't really associate it like like I
don't know sometimes a little creepy but
they're never like aggressive or kind of
what's so funny I actually you you want
me to give you Alpha to Y the
competitive trait is the clown need it
need it completely the competitive clown
is the competitive clown because I find
competition and clowns to be very
similar in culture which is they have
very opposite reactions pretty
aggressive there are people who are
[ __ ] petrified of clowns and there
are millions who adore them and they
bring them so much joy in their youth
right competitiveness there are so many
people in the last 30 40 years who've
tried to demonize it and take away
trophies and this that and the other
thing and meanwhile there's so many
people that view it as the core thing
that brings them happiness
and so like we've demonized competition
but there's many parts of the world that
think it's profoundly important and so
they both are actually going down the
same path when in reality it's right
down the middle like you know like you
don't need to be scared of clowns like
it's going to be okay and like it's okay
to be competitive but of course if
you're like so competitive that you're
like physically abusing people after you
lose to them which goes through my mind
when I lose stuff you know like I want
to fight you know like you know that's
that's unacceptable but being
competitive is an incredible driver to a
lot of people's happiness so I think
competition and being well block father
that's deep my guy I I will tell you the
most fun part for me about V friends
right now is how few people including my
team including Andy and let alone these
two may let alone like my most Inner
Circle have no idea how
um
how deep these things have been thought
through like grateful gar I would I
would say great gratefulness is my is my
fuel and like the gar is an animal that
you know like literally is Gary without
the why and so like when I was like
pairing it up I'm like this is important
like so there's a lot more thought and
wait till we start doing the children's
books and the cartoons and the movies
there's so much conversation we're like
I will say it again for the 97 000 time
this is what I'm gonna do for the rest
of my life and we're going to really
incredibly uh enjoy the process of
creating these characters and I think
the competitive clown is going to help a
lot of parents and kids in the 2030s the
2040s the 2050s and so it's exciting to
be in these early Journeys where you
know when I started Wine Library TV I
don't think people understood what that
was going to mean for me in the wine
business or in my life when I was you
know an early user of social media in
2006 I don't think people understood
like what that actually meant when I
started vaynermedia nobody understood
that I was going to change the entire
advertising industry and so I feel the
same way about be friends it's exciting
for me
all right let's show something else NG
like it's watching I'm about to give
away some of the pieces for free on
shopifriends.com the way you're going to
do that is you're going to Tweet out
your favorite piece on shop.vfriends.com
so get ready for that that'll be coming
up shortly
um let me just see my schedule here
because I know I have another meaning
you know I'll be good coming up shortly
um
and so you know you're gonna tweet out
to me hey garyvee Dustin start getting
this ready hey garyvee you don't have to
put it yet hey at garyvee this is my
favorite piece and then link your
favorite piece on
um
shop.vfriends.com so be ready for that
because after we hang up here I'm gonna
go to Twitter right away after I'm gonna
close with it then I'll probably hang on
for five more minutes then I'll give you
10 minutes after and I'm gonna pick
Seven Ten people five people whatever I
can have in between two meetings and
give away uh a bunch of pieces so
that'll be coming up but let's put back
the yeah you have that on hand good
awesome we'll bring that back up let's
put this because I want people to check
it out let's see the next piece perfect
you're fine
Claire come on in
this is Claire this is a little delayed
on there
go ahead introduce yourself so I'm a
cultural engagement manager at the
friends
look at that authentic Anaconda
um sorry there's just a little delay
over here G no no I'm I'm actually
responding to PA I'm responding to PA
Explorer in Discord because I appreciate
PA Explorer
um and uh I'm just letting you set up
the piece so go ahead for sure
um just going back to like us you know
listening to the community and seeing
feedback on the community and everything
right
um in the first in the spring drop we
had we had the genuine giraffe where
it's a genuine it had the giraffe print
in the graphic and
um we got a really really great response
to that piece that we're thinking in
this collection like how could we do
something similar and keep that energy
going because the community had said
they liked it so much so we extended it
here to the authentic graphic with just
like the print of the Anaconda within
the graphic and it's all embroidered and
um I know it's hard to see on the stream
but it came out really really clean
yeah the the this one is pretty [ __ ]
fresh like I like back to like when I
think about where I'm what I'm gonna
rock like
um you know it's kind of fun you know
fortnite chills has a few designs seem
off you know this is what's so fun about
fashion to me we just spent the first 15
minutes on this you cool kids like
oversized I lived that life in the 90s
everything was oversized I used to wear
jeans that I could fit my friends in
like and like now I want like soft and
fitted that's where I'm at but you know
back to like reading all the comments
it's fun to see like which ones really
rock for people but ironically this
authentic line the authentic Anaconda
has gotten probably the most positive
feedback from what I've been consuming
in the last hour like it seems like it's
really hit so talk to me about
authenticity you two sorry go ahead so
for me the virtues of authenticity are
just staying true to yourself and
staying true to others and also just not
letting external influences disrupt your
peace and your sense of self and
individuality
I love that I love that too I feel the
same and gee it's sick that like
everyone that's coming on like had their
option of picking what they wanted to
wear and this is what Lexie Claire chose
this oh is that right yes exactly so
everyone's like wearing like based on
like the trait that like jumped out
they're clear knowing how cool you are
like like it's uncomfortable I never
even want to be around you because
you're that cool like are you rocking
the authentic because of the word or
because the camo thing is so [ __ ]
Flex so many people talk about the
camo-ish part of the snake in the
authentic
um is it more what the word means to you
or do you just like from a aesthetic
standpoint you're like I like this
because it's got that black camo thing
that is you know kind of flexing for a
lot of people
I think definitely a mix of both it
initially caught my eye because
camo is one of one of your friends
uh
I really liked it
was also the word authentic really
resonates with me as well and just
trying to stay true to my own Vision
like with whatever project I'm working
on
I love it
Ben that's right how about you you were
forced to wear that shirt because you
were excited about the first 555 orders
like that was is that where you kind of
were more went
um
thanks Claire
um
thanks uh drock I literally did like I
didn't know you were there and literally
your lat like it's so funny
that was my mom and dad do all the time
how are you so did you also equally get
to choose something you did you were you
were allowed I won okay and so break it
down
I'm working with your great year I mean
but
building slowly and I think that a lot
of your audience especially the people
that have been with you for a long time
realize where you came from and kind of
how you've been able to build your brand
over the last 12 15 years and I think is
a very important lesson that a lot of
people need to learn I I myself had to
learn it uh I learned that working with
you a lot you know is it something you
still struggle with you shared something
so publicly like kind of like the other
day on social and I was like I was
wondering if it was patience for more
enjoyment like where do you sit
unnaturally being good at it versus
working on it
I think I'm naturally good at hitting
like long term I think I have a good
understanding of time I just sometimes
feel like I am bad at hey this will take
two more years until I can get to the
spot where I feel good about it if that
makes sense of course macro micro
always
see what about you is there and this
design is fresh by the way I love them
Panda Geezer is there a piece that
stands out to you the most
let me look real quick while you guys
you guys are such stupid well first of
all the sweatpants stand out
I used to make fun of AJ in my brain not
directly of how much sweatpants he wore
when he was in college whoa yeah
no question the thing that stood out for
me Ben yes I used to make fun of AJ like
we'll get you on in a minute James uh I
used to make fun of AJ a lot in my brain
because he would always Rock sweatpants
and I was so jeansed out but something
has happened in the last you know I
think it was coven right I was wearing
sweatpants probably so much because I
didn't have to [ __ ] and then now like
traveling
when I TR you know this drock like how
many times I you know I mean
a shirt now you're like no but you
definitely know what I'm about to say
drock for years when we were traveling
like insanity the second we would pull
up to the airport I would switch out
of whatever I was wearing and I would
open my luggage and I would put a hoodie
on and a beanie and turn into airport
Gary and call it a day
I've now noticed that I want to travel
with sweatpants the weird part is I have
a real system for my wallet my
headphones my wallet my phone as you
know drock headphones not as much but
wallet and phone I'm unstoppable I don't
lose them because I have a whole touch
thing but with sweatpants it could like
slip out it [ __ ] me up but punchline
being
um
I'm so much more into sweatpants now
that off top the biggest thing that has
my attention with the collection is the
sweatpants is that because I'm covered I
feel like your whole life yeah yeah yeah
and then I'm probably gonna say
cream selfless
I think cream selfless looks [ __ ]
insane
and black Anaconda
and then Navy grateful long tea
those are ones that kind of like are
making me feel it right now and like a
little bit and like so I love patience
the problem is we've been pumping
patient pandas so much like I'm in this
new place where I like want to talk
about all the characters this is just me
as a human being it's like supply and
demand like if you eat your favorite you
know thing too much you kind of get to
get off of it I'm like a little bit like
rare robot patient pan empathy although
I'm like you know no like selfless sloth
or authentic Anaconda so I'm a little
bit that's affecting me a little bit
right now I can sense it but visually
like no [ __ ] if it was like any
brand not be friends I think selfless
selfless hoodie cream sweatpants combo
would crush for me love it and and this
means for the future we need uh garyvee
um sweatpant with zipper pockets
yes it's logical lion Jennifer and be
friends land
um
shop.bfriends.com we're about to give
away several pieces
so
um get ready for that I'm looking
forward to that uh and we'll keep going
with that all right let's see James Cook
in the full grip
very comfy yeah stand up for you all
James do you like why James do you like
the wide sleeve t-shirt thing the cool
because it makes your arms look like
twigs
well you know I do have to work out a
little bit so not bad you don't have
that going for me but no this is a
medium tea and
honestly I do like the oversized because
I am a hypebeast but yeah if I would
have ordered this online I'm 5 10 I
would have got a large I would have been
swimming in a large yeah okay it is
oversized I'm the same way this is a
medium and normally I'm like a large
extra large and it didn't even do it Ben
this is why I'm buying small on on the
you know yeah same with the same with
the sweatpants hold on real quick I
apologize yes Clayton Andrew shell I'm
about to give away some be friends drip
uh in a little bit we're gonna do it on
Twitter so make sure you have a Twitter
account I'm going to tell you all what
to do in a little bit and I'm gonna give
away
um you know uh the way I'm gonna do it
is I'm milking this as long as I can I
got a little bit of a client fire
meeting that I have to do but I just I'm
enjoying hanging out we're having a lot
of fun on this big day when we drop the
winter collection of be friends apparel
uh so but I'm gonna prep it for five
minutes here so everybody who's watching
gets a shot then I'm going to uh then
I'm going to uh go to my meeting but in
between my meeting I'm just going to see
all the tweets star or I'm just going to
reply to be friends winner winner winner
winner winner bang out you know three
four seven nine something whatever I can
do between walking to the client over
there in a three four seven nine ten
twelve with you know we'll figure it out
um
uh and the way we're gonna do it is
you're gonna go to shop.b friends.com
and pick your favorite item link it into
your Tweet we'll tell you exactly how to
do it so uh get ready looking forward to
it James you look cool man
thank you
what's up you like sweatpants or no no
man I'm a jeans guy yeah
the black cat I mean like I would
definitely Rock these
yeah they're coffee too embroidered
black cat yeah
that was a call for me she really wanted
embroidered
May is in charge that's right Geo would
also say too if people are getting the
t's
um and they're a little oversized like
the t's like both the t-shirt and the
long sleeve are 100 cotton if you wash
it in hot water and dry it like well the
first time it will shrink up a little
bit understood good good to know uh What
uh what else do we have there we want
anything yeah
well I'm a little drock because we're
always wearing fish and Panda right now
you like the gray with the black writing
drock get in there I want to see them
side by side yeah
I also see what oh I like the green can
I see what Dustin's wearing because I
know it's not be friends stuff I just
want to see what he's actually wearing
everyone
you all look very cute wait a minute
this looks like a holiday card drock get
in there get in frame I just wanna Just
Wanna I'm gonna take a little photo
smile guys a little hot little holiday
card bang thank you thanks awesome
I know it's like kind of a last minute
here there's
um the classic pieces on the site right
yes be friends core items do you have a
favorite colorway yeah I mean look I
mean I know we really built a bunch of
like
um I like the gray a lot I like the gray
a lot I do not agree
I do like the green like yeah I'm pretty
excited about this like we haven't had
the green like the green
long sleeve
is something I'm definitely gonna pick
up
I'm gonna rock that
um all right let's ask questions I want
to answer a bunch of questions Dustin
let's do that I want you to stay there
may get the rock into the screen too you
can make me small
um if you have a question I see a bunch
of you right now uh please put hashtag
question and ask your question we'll
give you a bunch of questions after the
next five to ten minutes and then uh
when hats Ben the hats that I saw from
you that's for next spring yes okay so
spring
and then the little collaboration I want
to do with that startup that I met at
vikon could that happen before
yes yep so we don't know and we got to
figure that out okay yeah okay
cool
uh Justin you're in charge just fire
away with the questions
cool
uh and then here we get in like
Christmas
Ben are they gonna be before Christmas
yeah um um
if if people order today right like they
should get a
um they'll get an order confirmation
they'll get a tracking number on it
obviously like the closer it gets to
Christmas the the more difficult it is
but um everybody that's ordering us
definitely
yeah December 8th U.S what about
International
it's a little weird I'm so scared email
from lynchie exactly I sent you from
Lindsay about the toys
Customs everyone will have a tracking
number domestic for sure
okay cool well we did different for this
drop was actually on our website before
we would have folks pay for Customs when
it reached their country and a lot of
them would be stuck there and get sent
back so now we actually Implement on our
website so when you actually check out
it includes custom so when it hits your
country it goes straight to you for me
the reason question is why grateful gar
over gratitude gorilla gratitude gorilla
obviously already was in the toy line I
want to do more stuff but more
importantly I want the word to represent
people like looking at drock and may
right now I'm imagining
them walking past me in an airport and
I'm like oh patient like I like that you
know like they're patient right like I
just there's something there to me
grateful means I may who just passed you
I'm grateful versus gratitude it plays a
little different so it's self-expression
through the words that's why grateful
over gratitude
are they soft or 100 cotton stuff from
Joanne Ben 80 cotton 20 polyester soft I
like how Adam's described it which is
like you would sleep in this
or yeah by the way by the way
I just I have a huge insight to why I've
worn The Grateful gar
hoodie sample you
large for me and I'm gonna go with small
when I get my original [ __ ] uh why did
that happen it's because
um
it's soft and the reason I wear hoodies
when I travel is to sleep on the plane
with the hoodie over my head and so this
series I'm buying for that
which the last one
then you made them hard class you know
like the cool thing
you know thank you yeah shout out to
everyone that loved the drop in Spring
the heavy ones and by the way Jeremy H
80 cotton we made it so it would shrink
a little bit because that gives people
control if it's slightly oversized a
little bit you know
uh MF Santa said kids size soon man I
know I don't want to give away too much
but let's just smile and move on all
right next question when will we get a
zip up Hoodie Ben why have we not had a
bit of is it could be not cool Ben and
that's why we haven't had one right now
is zip hoodies are super cool and we and
we can definitely have one we can
definitely have one we'll just work on
one that makes sense for sure Ben can we
do a couple of things in a very small
little batch like look I think I already
went into Discord and said I'm going to
do this we do need like a 40 50 hoodie
thing I think we need to attack that but
then maybe also like a zip like smaller
little something for like February or
March before the spring launch that
maybe addresses some of these things as
you gather the feedback yep yeah
do it next does
I'm still looking okay no worries
um then let's tell everybody how you win
because I'm gonna have to leave soon for
this client thing everybody's watching
I'm about to give away some swag
so we've got a little sense now at
shop.bfriends.com
um
if you go to shop.bfriends.com and pick
your favorite
uh peace uh
then what I need you to do is tweet me
right I'm gonna need you to tweet me do
you have Dustin the way we're gonna do
this so uh go to Twitter and put you've
got to put hey at garyvee this has to be
exact hey at garyvee
this is my favorite piece Dustin I don't
like the way you have that up but hey
garyvee this is my favorite type that
out instead of your favorite piece in
parentheses dust change that to hey
garyvee this is my favorite and then the
link hey garyvee this is my favorite and
then the link
because then I could just search people
that mention my name while I go to my
meeting
like a bunch of them or I'm just gonna
reply to be friends say winner winner
winner yep hey garyvee this is my
favorite and a link and then Dustin put
add link but then put shop.vfriends.com
after that so then we can just hold this
up here the whole time and I can for the
last five
seven minutes I can uh get everybody to
understand how they can win let me go to
my Discord and let them know
away pieces
yeah everyone come in real quick we're
gonna do one little last time
you were all coming in for one last shot
comcar asked about uh we didn't do any
unique um you know we're doing a lot of
things for holders we've done stuff with
Apparel in the past we didn't do it on
this drop cam but we have a bunch of
stuff coming in a lot
uh on the horizon for holders of V1 or
V2 so that's the information on that all
right little group photo get in there
take your photo I'm going to screenshot
this very cool
very nice good Smiles James you have a
good smile man thank you you're welcome
all right
I reach out for a bunch of cuties um all
right here's here's they're all they're
all rocking their favorite they had all
the choices to do that
Benz is unavailable if you're following
earlier today then t-shirt was was
completely based on the first 555 orders
but for everybody watching right now
who's not bought one on
shop.bfriends.com and would like one
maybe they can't afford it or maybe it's
just fun to win free shipped the way you
do that is right now
um
for the next five to ten minutes before
I do my four o'clock meeting
you can uh go to Twitter and tweet hey
garyvee this is my favorite and then
link which of the one pieces uh are your
favorite and I would love to give away a
bunch and so uh hope we can do that
thank you team uh just gonna read some
comments a little bit more here we're
gonna keep that up I'm gonna tell
everybody how they can do so leg can't
afford this is exactly why I'm doing
this hopefully a bunch of people can get
one
um one more time here is how you get a
free piece any of those that you might
like the best go to twitter.com I'll go
to Twitter excuse me and go put tweet
out hey at garyvee this is my favorite
and then link one of the items from
shop.bfriends.com
um I'm really excited about it I want to
wish everybody uh a happy uh uh holiday
I hope everybody has a great Christmas
um or whatever you were celebrating
Hanukkah Kwanza all the great stuff
um really excited to you know actually
get to interact with a bunch of you
um
because uh during the holidays I have a
little bit more down time ironically in
between like family stuff and shopping
and this and that like so it's gonna be
a lot of fun to be able to do that uh
Stephen Stillwell big North Hunter
didn't represent I went to that High
School uh it's a weedy witty weasels
winter I like that uh
but like John uh Joe good to see you one
more time for people joining us late
um
I literally have beef
Twitter just for view friends it's
perfect I really hope a bunch of you win
this I'm actually gonna probably cut
short so I can pick a couple more
winners
um if you would like uh Dustin maybe you
can split screenshot.viewfriends.com
with me right now
um could be fun uh if you would like a
uh a piece from this collection for free
I'm going to do a little uh Santa work
here on Twitter right now go to Twitter
and tweet hey garyvee this is my
favorite with a link to whichever piece
is your favorite on shop.bfriends.com
um and um
I'm excited Stefano asked good to see
you
uh let's see who else is here Ellie G
Paul H in the building Liam d
um great to see you Derek duck
um Sebastian thank you for joining
Seacrest uh great to see you all right
yeah I'm gonna spend a couple extra
minutes I guess I'm downloading Twitter
love that
um
great to see you awesome I'll see you
soon thank you thanks Dustin
you got it